me da gusto que estén de regreso pues el
vídeo pasado yo les había mostrado que
si nosotros tenemos una casa en renta y
una casa en venta y las dos son casas
iguales y bueno los precios de rentar y
de comprar al final son números eso
depende del mercado que haya en tu
localidad pero sin entrar en por mayores
yo te había demostrado que cuando tú
compramos una casa estaba quemando 40
mil pesos de tu dinero mientras que
cuando renta va solamente quemadas 26
mil pesos de tu dinero y bueno esto sin
entrar en por mayores sin contar por
ejemplo qué es lo que pasa con otros
impuestos o con otros precios pero al
final esta cantidad de dinero es la
cantidad de dinero que tú vas a perder
de tu bolso no es una cantidad de dinero
que vaya a ir a tu capital o una
cantidad de dinero que vaya a aumentar
el precio de la casa es la cantidad de
dinero que simple y sencillamente se va
a quemar es un dinero que tú nunca vas a
volver a ver y es que al final cuando tú
pienso un préstamo para comprar una casa
entonces estás rentando una cierta
cantidad de dinero el interés es una
renta y es que al final cuando tú tienes
un activo no se ese activo que sea tu
dinero o inclusive una casa
pero tú te ves una ciudad de cantidad de
dinero por tener ese cierto activo
entonces el interés es la renta de tu
pago mensual al final es tu elección si
quieres ser un inquilino de una deuda o
un inquilino de una casa pero lo que sí
te demostré es que si eres un deudor o
un retador o un inquilino de dinero vas
a perder casi el doble de dinero que lo
que pérdidas rentando la casa bueno eso
sí uno de los argumentos negativos que
tú podrías utilizar a tu favor es que me
subiera en la renta supongamos que me
suben la renta en el siguiente año o
después de unos ciertos años a 3.500
cuánto es 3.5 por 12 bueno 3.5 por 12 42
y si a esto le sumamos los 10 mil pesos
que yo tenía de interés por mis 250 mil
pesos es más 10 no nos pueden más bienes
menos 10 puntos sería menos 20 son 32
mil pesos al final tienes razón las
rentas suben después de un cierto tiempo
pero aunque me fui a la renta 500 pesos
yo sigo pagando 32 mil pesos a
comparación de los 42 mil casi 42 mil
pesos que tú pagas al compra
a casa y es más hasta podemos calcular
la cantidad de dinero que nosotros
tendremos que pagar de renta para perder
41 mil 500 pesos de nuestro bolsillo
entonces tenemos 41 mil 500 pesos más 10
mil pesos que nos da el banco son 51 mil
500 pesos por lo tanto vamos a poner los
51 mil 500 pesos dividido entre 12 meses
51 mil 500 dividido entre 12 meses me va
a dar la cantidad de dinero que me
tendrían que cobrar de venta para que
las cuentas fueran iguales y son 4 mil
300 pesos entonces vamos a escribirlo 4
mil 300 pesos para que las cuentas sean
iguales es decir que la cantidad de
dinero que perdemos rentando una casa
sea igual a la cantidad de dinero que
perdemos cuando compramos una casa otro
punto a favor es que cuando tú te
quieras cambiar de casa o necesites
cambiarte de esa casa entonces vas a ir
a rentar una nueva casa y vas a poner
esta casa en renta en cuánto tiempo tú
vas a necesitar alquilar esta casa para
que tú no salgas perdiendo nada en
ningún mes y bueno hay que tener cuidado
porque otros argumentos demoníacos que
te podrían dar es decirte que tu casa se
va a apreciar o va a aumentar de valor
cada
año que pase sin embargo esto no es
cierto y se nota actualmente en eeuu las
casas se están bajando de valor pero
bueno vamos a suponer que sí es cierto
que las casas van a aumentar de valor
cuánto se tendrá que apreciar esta casa
para que las cuentas fueran iguales
entonces cuántos 41 mil 500 si a esto le
quitamos lo que perdíamos en la otra
casa que eran 26 mil pesos entonces me
salen 15 mil 500 pesos 15 mil 500 pesos
es más favorable el caso de rentar al
caso de comprar una casa ahora bien
vamos a suponer que lo que queremos es
que esta casa se aprecie esta cantidad
de dinero para que me sea más favorable
comprar una casa entonces voy a hacer 15
mil 500 ya esto lo voy a dividir entre
lo que vale mi casa que si lo ponemos en
punto decimal van a ser 1000 y esto me
va a salir 0.01 55